there was another special election
yesterday this one in Ohio's 12th
district and as of just minutes ago the
race still officially too close to call
although the Republican candidate in the
official results is ahead by about 1700
votes but this is still massive massive
news and the Republicans are trying to
downplay it but the big news wouldn't be
that the Republican one if the
Republican does end up winning by the
current count of like I said 1,700 votes
the news is the Republican didn't win
easily because this is a hugely
massively read district 87% white
district that hasn't had a democratic
representative since 1983 35 years ago
before I was born and certainly before
Pat was born and in total has had only
one Democratic Representative dating all
the way back to 1939 seventy-nine years
you have to go back for the second
democratic representative in Ohio's 12th
district and more impressively only one
of the last forty-one terms were held by
a Democrat of course when you consider
the the number of terms that the
Republicans have served compared to the
Democrats you have to go back to 1939
not just for the second Democrat to
control this district to to be the
representative for this district but
just for the second term during which
the seat was filled by a Democrat as I
mentioned the voting results as of very
very recently just hours ago 1,700 votes
separating Republican Troy Ball derson
from Democrat Danny O'Connor and as of
right now even if the Republican eats
out this victory whether it's 1,700
votes or 2,200 or 1,300 pending a
recount absentee ballots that still have
to be counted as well as provisional
ballots this is a red flag for
Republicans in November does this mean
Republicans need to assume Democrats
have it in the bag no does this mean
Democratic voters can stay home because
Democrats are just gonna kill it in
November absolutely and totally not does
this mean that if something big happens
like Trump invading Iran Republicans
can't have
massive gains because of those bogus
talking points like you can't switch
horses midstream when it comes to
military engagements no all of that
stuff can happen but what it does mean
is that this is a big change of
direction in a massively red district
Republicans had to spend millions in
this race to eke out what is maybe a
1,700 vote victim victory you had here a
race that Donald Trump won this district
easily Mitt Romney won this district
easily and it was so tight that Trump
personally went to Ohio to campaign for
the Republican over the last few days
and still we have the possibility that
the Democrat could win although not not
hugely likely based on the number of
votes this is very bad news for
Republicans cautiously potentially good
news for Democrats but I I don't want a
single Democrat in any district thinking
it's okay to stay home because of these
results right because past performance
isn't necessarily indicative of future
results sure so maybe the best attitude
we can have when it comes to this is
just to treat all races as if they're
50/50 if we do have a shot at winning
this but you have to go out and vote you
can't rest on your laurels according to
the cook Political Report there are
right now of the 435 House seats all of
which of course are up for re-election
there are 68 seats that are currently
held by Republicans that are more in
favor of Democrats than Ohio's 12th
district Democrats need 23 seats in the
house a net gain of 23 to take control
of the house and 68 Republican seats
right now have better numbers for the
Democratic candidate then the Ohio 12th
congressional district that is maybe
part of if we had to come up with like
is there anything good about Trump being
in the White House there's very little
good about it right if there's anything
that we can say might be a positive side
effect of Trump being in the White House
it's that it's created a little bit of
space for some progressive ideas to be
floated around and it turns out that a
lot of those ideas are really popular
and more popular with Republicans than
maybe we were pretending for a very long
time there's new polling which points
out that a Federal jobs guarantee has
more than 50% support nationally that
means that there are Republicans who
support it community job creation
programs more than 50% of the country
supports it government producing generic
pharmaceutical drugs more than half the
country supports it a public internet
utility basic health care services for
all every single one of those ideas has
higher than 50% support sometimes way
higher than 50% support and one
advantage I would say the one advantage
to Trump in the White House has been
that some Democrats especially some of
the more progressive candidates have
decided to just say the things that
they're for when before they might have
been more posturing and coy and your
calculated political II not that I say
not that that's a good thing but it's
good that they're now actually saying
these are things that I'm for and what
we are finding is that among moderate
Republicans some of these ideas are
actually relatively popular so it's a
good sign for Democrats in the fall it's
not a good sign for Republicans but
nothing is guaranteed and I think Pat's
idea of consider every seat fifty-fifty
if you think about it as it's 80% chance
that the Republican wins you might stay
home if you think about it as it's 80%
chance that the Democrat wins you also
might stay home think of every race is
50/50 nothing is guaranteed get out
there and in the context of looking at
data to figure out what might be
happening in the midterms there's one
other big piece of news from last night
which is that for the first time ever
voters have blocked one of those
horrible right-to-work laws that was
passed by Republicans its massive and
that's what I want to talk about next